POLITICAL WORLD.
AMOROSO IS OUT.
WE GO TO WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS
FOR A RESPONSE.
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT?
WE HAVE TAPE OF HOW IT MIGHT
HAVE HUNG FOLDED.
>> OMAROSA, YOU WAIT OUTSIDE.
FOR WEEKS.
YOU ARE FIRED.
>> Greg: NO, THANK YOU.
DOUG JONES WINS.
ROY MOORE LOSES.
AND AL FRANKEN KEEPS HIS PAJAMAS
BUMMED BECAUSE REPUBLICANS LOST,
IT MAKES IT HARDER TO FULFILL
TRUMP'S AGENDA.
TO THEM, I SAY RELAX.
THE SILVER LINING IS BIGGER THAN
THE CLOUD.
NO REFERENDUM ON TRUMP.
IT'S A REFERENDUM ON A STATE
ELECTION THAT MADE ALL OF US
SQUIRM, INCLUDING YOU.
YOU CAN TELL BY TRUMP'S POLITE
TWEET AFTER HE WAS RELIEVED NOT
TO HAVE THIS ALBATROSS AROUND
HIS NECK.
THE ONLY REASON WE HAVE THE
SELECTION WAS BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP WON.
IT'S TRUE.
IMAGINE IT'S OCTOBER 2016 AND A
GENIE OFFERS YOU THIS DEAL.
YOU CAN WIN THE WHITE HOUSE,
LOSE A SENATE SEAT IN A YEAR.
WOULDN'T YOU TAKE THAT DEAL?
OF COURSE HE WOULD.
SURE, THE REPUBLICANS BLEW THE
PRIMARY WHICH GOT US THIS MESS
BUT IT COULD BE WORSE.
YOU COULD STILL HAVE THAT SEAT
BUT UNDER HILLARY.
AS FOR YOU, DOUG JONES, STOP
GRINNING AND OPEN YOUR MIND.
YOU ARE ALREADY A LAME DUCK.
A LEFTY IN ALABAMA IS LIKE A
POPSICLE IN A SAUNA WHICH IS WHY
YOU NEARLY LOST TO THE MOST
FLAWED CANDIDATE EVER.
SAVED BY REPUBLICAN WRITE-INS.
GRAB LUNCH WITH THE PRESIDENT.
YOU ALREADY HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON WITH HIM.
YOUR OPPONENT SUCKED.
LET'S GET TO THE BIG NEWS.
OMAROSA.
DANA, DEVASTATED?
>> Dana: I'VE ONLY MET HER
ONCE.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW HER BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE STORY
BEHIND WHY SHE LEFT.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: NOT THIS NETWORK, I
DON'T THINK.
WE ARE HEARING NEW SHE WAS
ESCORTED OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
BY ARMED SECURITY BECAUSE SHE
ISSUED SOME VULGARITIES TO
GENERAL KELLY AND CLAIMS CREDIT
FOR THE TRUMP ELECTION.
"YOU CAN'T FIRE ME.
>> Greg: THERE IS ALWAYS
SOMEBODY NOBODY LIKES.
NOBODY COULD GET ALONG WITH
OMAROSA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: SHE WAS LIKE, I AM
FRIENDS WITH TRUMP.
I HAVE A HALL PASS.
CAMPAIGN.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS DIDN'T
THINK HE WOULD WIN.
SHE WAS SOMEONE WHO WORKED FOR
HIM WHEN ALMOST NO ONE ELSE
WOULD.
SHE GOT REWARDED WITH A
WHITE HOUSE JOB WHICH A LOT OF
US OR SORT OF CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> Dana: THE WOMAN FROM
CHICAGO, THEY GOT IN FIGHTS.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT OMAROSA OR
THE ELECTION?
>> Kimberly: ALL OF THIS.
>> Greg: IS THIS A BLOW TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION?
>> Kimberly: BELIEVE ME.
THEY ARE LIKE, D- HOW MANY DAYS
FOR HER TO GO?
NO SURPRISE.
THE ONLY SHOCKING THING IS SHE
LASTED THIS LONG TO BE QUITE
HONEST.
SHE HAS A BONE TO PICK WITH
EVERYBODY.
ISSUES FROM THE MINUTE SHE WAS
WEDDING PARTY THERE?
>> Marie: THERE WERE STORIES
ABOUT HOW SHE WOULD LEAVE PAIRS
HAPPY ABOUT THIS.
>> Greg: OBVIOUSLY THE BIGGER
STORY, DANA, THERE'S A LOT OF
FINGER-POINTING.
SHOULDN'T THE REPUBLICANS BE
INCREDIBLY RELIEVED?
>> Dana: I WAS LIKE YOU ARE
>> Greg: ALWAYS PLUGGING YOUR
BOOK.
>> Dana: I TAKE ISSUE WITH A
LITTLE SOMETHING.
I THINK THE WRITE-INS WERE
SOMETHING THAT I THINK YOU HAVE
TO HAND IT TO THE DEMOCRATS ON
THE GRASSROOTS IN TERMS OF
TURNOUT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE AGREEING WITH
STEVE BANNON.
[LAUGHS]
>> Dana: THAT THAT THAT
DEMOCRATS HAD GOOD TURNOUT?
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
IF STEVE BANNON AGREES WITH ME
ON THAT, IT'S LIKE AGREEING THIS
SPIDER IS BLUE.
>> Greg: IS THAT REALLY BLEW?
I DON'T KNOW.
FAKE NEWS.
JESSE, DOESN'T MAKE IT HARDER TO
IMPLEMENT TRUMP'S AGENDA?
>> Jesse: NO, I THINK THEY
HAVE THE VOTES FOR TAX CUTS.
DEMOCRATS DID NOT WIN.
ROY MOORE LOST.
IF I WAS A DEMOCRAT, I WOULDN'T
BE EXCITED ABOUT BARELY BEATING
IT CANDIDATE WHO WAS CREDIBLY
ACCUSED OF MOLESTING LITTLE
KIDS.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
YOU WANT TO HANG YOUR HAT ON.
JONES HAD NO MANDATE EITHER.
HE'S GOING TO BE A LAME DUCK.
IN TWO YEARS, HE'S GOING TO BE
BEATEN BY NORMAL REPUBLICAN.
HE MIGHT AS WELL CAUCUS WITH THE
MAJORITY.
THIS GUY, NO ONE WANTED HIM TO
WIN.
I DON'T THINK THE REPUBLICANS
CARED ABOUT THE SEAT.
THIS GUY WAS A FRINGE CANDIDATE,
A RURAL GUY WHO WAS A BOMB
THROWER, AND THE SUBURBS DIDN'T
PLAY, HE WON BLACK WOMEN, HE WON
I DON'T BLAME MITCH MCCONNELL.
MITCH MCCONNELL PICKED THE RIGHT
HORSE, LUTHER STRANGE FROM THE
JUMP.
SO DID DONALD TRUMP.
McCONNELL HAS BEEN WARNING
ABOUT THESE BOMB THROWERS IN THE
SENATE RACES, THE -- SHANNON
ENGEL, THE WITCH.
WE CAN SEE THIS COMING.
>> Greg: TRUMP PICKED THE
LET'S ROLL SOME TAPE.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE COUNTRY TO GET IT RIGHT, NOT
BECAUSE WE LOST A SEAT.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS FEEL
DIFFERENTLY.
THEY ARE HAPPY WITH THE WAY IT
TURNED OUT BUT I WOULD HAVE, AS
A LEADER OF THE PARTY, WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO OF HAD THE SEAT.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT TO ME IT'S
VERY, VERY JUST VERY IMPORTANT
TO GET THIS VOTE NOT BECAUSE OF
THAT BUT BECAUSE, AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE VOTE WILL BE.
GREAT VICE PRESIDENT.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
VOTE.
PEOPLE.
I CAN TELL HE WAS IN THAT BROKEN
UP ABOUT IT.
>> Kimberly: NO, BUT HE'S A
BUSINESSMAN.
YOU'VE GOT TO MOVE FORWARD.
OKAY, THIS IS A BAD DEAL, DIDN'T
WORK OUT BUT HE'S PROBABLY
THINKING I PICKED THE RIGHT GUY
TO BEGIN WITH.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE -- BE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION IF LUTHER
STRANGE WAS IN IT.
IT WAS SHOCKING, THE FACT THAT
WERE CALLING FOR HIM TO DROP OUT
HE WAS DOWN BY HOW MANY
PERCENTAGE POINTS.
I THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
WOULD HAVE BEEN GREAT IF WE HAD
PEOPLE AND GETTING TAX REFORM
THROUGH.
HE'S DONE.
THAT'S IN THE REARVIEW MIRROR.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK
AS HE IS PERCEIVED TO BE?
LIKE I SAID, A POPSICLE IN A
SAUNA.
HE'S NOT GOING TO LAST LONG IN
ALABAMA.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE,
RIGHT?
>> Marie: I THINK HE WILL
CAUCUS WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FEELS PRETTY GOOD AFTER LAST
REAL POLITICAL RECKONING THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY GOING INTO 2018.
MIDTERMS ARE HISTORICALLY BAD
FOR INCUMBENTS.
DONALD TRUMP AND THE RNC WENT IN
BEHIND THIS CANDIDATE.
AND MODERATE REPUBLICANS CROSSED
OVER IN PRETTY BIG NUMBERS.
THEY DIDN'T JUST WRITE IN
WHITE WOMEN, YOUNG VOTERS.
IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY DOESN'T
TAKE THIS RESULT SERIOUSLY GOING
INTO 2018, I THINK THEY WILL
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS.
>> Greg: IS MARIE SAYING DON'T
LISTEN TO BANNON?
>> Marie: I AM.
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T SHARE ALL
THE BLAME.
HE GOT IN AFTER MOORE WAS UP BY
DOUBLE DIGITS.
LISTEN, THIS GUY'S NATIONAL P.R.
SPOKESMAN HAD A BRAIN FREEZE ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION YESTERDAY.
HE SAID GAYS SHOULD BE IN JAIL.
HE SAID MUSLIMS COULDN'T SERVE
IN THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
AND HE WAS DRENCHED IN SCANDAL.
THIS IS NOT A NORMAL REPUBLICAN
HAIR, I DON'T GET SPEAKS WELL
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Marie: THE RNC CHOSE TO
BACK HIM AFTER THESE ALLEGATIONS
CAME OUT.
CANDIDATES LIKE ROY MOORE OR
SUPPORT ESTABLISHMENT
CANDIDATES.
NONROY MOORE CANDIDATES.
>> Dana: THERE'S A PHENOMENON
THAT'S INTERESTING.
WHEN OBAMA WAS RUNNING FOR
ELECTION, HE WON AND HE WAS FINE
AND HE COULD HELP BRING PEOPLE
ALONG.
IF HE'S NOT ON THE BALLOT, THAT
IT'S NOT SO GOOD FOR THAT PARTY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ELECTIONS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
SINCE, IF HE'S NOT AT THE TOP OF
THE TICKET, EVEN IF HE'S
CAMPAIGNING, EVEN SUPPORTIVE AND
TWEETING ABOUT YOU, IT'S NOT
WORKING.
THE GENERIC BALLOT FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL RACES IN THE
MIDTERMS ARE NOT GOOD FOR
REPUBLICANS RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS A 15-POINT GAP IN THE
POLL TODAY.
YOU CAN MAKE UP A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT WITH THE TAX REFORM BILL OF
THE ECONOMY CONTINUES TO IMPROVE
BUT I THINK MARIE IS RIGHT.
THERE IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT
TO DO.
>> Greg: DEFINITELY.
SHOULD MOORE PURSUE LEGALLY WHAT
HAPPENED AND POLITICALLY?
IF HE BELIEVES HE IS INNOCENT,
SHOULD HE BE LIKE O.J.?
FIND THE REAL KILLER?
>> Greg: THE ONLY ONE WHO CAME
TO MIND.
>> Kimberly: IF IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HIM HE SHOULDN'T TRY TO CLEAR
HIS NAME.
BUT AGAIN, I CAN'T BELIEVE HE
DID AS WELL AS HE DID IN THE
POLLS AND OBVIOUSLY DEMOCRATS,
WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY, IT'S
GOING TO BE ABOUT TURNOUT AND
ELECTIONS OR LOCAL CONGRESSIONAL
RACES.
>> Greg: THEY GOT LUCKY WITH
THIS CANDIDATE.
>> Dana: A5 TO ONE ADVANTAGE
IN TERMS OF REGISTERED
REPUBLICANS OVER DEMOCRATS.
I THINK IT IS REMARKABLE HE WON.